everyone this is feed a master Costa
Cove it's key here for Ches calm and
today I wanted to go over something
that's really critical for anyone who
wants to get better at chess and I do
mean anyone okay so if you're an
aspiring chess player and you want to
get better you need to learn how to
learn from your own games okay you need
to play a lot of training games against
serious opponents and try to win and you
need to then go over those games either
with a friend who also wants to do some
chess analysis or with an engine or just
by yourself but what's important is that
you find your mistakes and you try to
understand why you made those mistakes
and you definitely look for an
improvement and that's important because
although no two chess games are really
ever the same you are going to come
across sort of familiar positions
positions that you've not exactly had
before but maybe you've had a similar
kind of position before and by analyzing
that previous position in depth you then
have this knowledge and experience that
you can use in your future games
so today I wanted to show you guys an
example of how going over one of my own
games really helped me in a future game
and was really beneficial to my my own
chess understanding okay so in this
position here I was playing white
against a very good opponent who I
believe is now an international master
and as you can see why it's Knight is
attacked by this pawn here and I have to
figure out what to do about this threat
so during the game I spent a lot of time
and I was able to find the best move
actually I found the best move really
quickly but I was not able to bring
myself to play it so if you want take a
couple minutes pause the video and
try to see if you can find the best move
and evaluate what's going on in the
position okay
so the best move here is rook takes d6
white sacrifices the exchange in order
to well do a couple of things basically
white just removes blacks best piece
hopefully you guys paused your videos
and tried to figure out what was going
on and if you did then then hopefully
you took stock of which pieces are good
and which pieces are bad and in this
position the 996 is absolutely the best
piece on the whole board the first thing
is that it's attacking this critical c4
pawn right and this is a huge weakness
for y and if y it loses this pawn then
their whole position is just going to
collapse
furthermore the knight is also
controlling the important efore square
and overall has very good presence in
the center black has to take the rook
and now Knight h5 so the threat is
Knight f6 check but the point of this
exchange sacrifice was not just to
threaten to win the exchange back
actually what it does is gives black
this weird pawn structure which actually
makes the three pieces on the Queen side
quite terrible like this Bishop is never
going to be able to get out and if it
ever comes to a six well okay it hits
the c-4 pawn but it doesn't really do
anything from there why this Bishop is
going to stay on d3 defend the c4 pawn
and blacks Bishop on a6 isn't actually
doing anything next is this night the
knight cannot go to be four you can go
to c7 but then what right it has to go
to eight and then it might not be able
to go to f6 and then if it goes to g7
where does it go from there and finally
the rooks are disconnected black has an
extra route for a minor piece but this
rook on a8 is not doing anything and
it's going to take several moves before
it gets into play so why is all that
important well it means that white is up
a lot of time
right black needs four or five moves to
coordinate their pieces and why it only
needs a few moves to start attacking
these pawns on the kingside so White's
next moves are like Bishop d3 and
possibly 93 maybe King F - Bishop d2 and
bringing the rook to the H file and once
white starts attacking these pawns
they're just going to fall because black
doesn't have any pieces that can really
protect them and if white wins these two
pawns then obviously they'll have a
completely winning position I mean a
bishop and two pawns two connected
passed pawns is definitely worth more
than a rook especially here since all of
ice pieces are already coordinated very
well so I'll give you guys like a sample
variation here let's say King g7 it
should be 397 black cannot even think
about defending this pawn y can just
play Knight G 3 next and take it and why
plays Knight G 3 bishop a six-night
takes an e4 and as you can see black has
made a couple of moves but is nowhere
near untangling this bishop is still
doing nothing this night is very passive
and this rook is still stuck in the
corner
even if black plays this move here b5 Y
can simply just ignore this threat you
know you can just play King F 2 takes
bishop c2 and these pieces still cannot
get active so white is probably going to
win this pawn next this pawn is hanging
y can take that pawn at any time
I think strategically White has a
completely winning position and so I
checked this with the computer and
indeed it was winning and during the
game I thought it was a really strong
possibility but I just couldn't bring
myself to do it it was very unclear you
know I didn't want to risk losing by
sacrificing material and I didn't go for
it so you know later I was pretty upset
because if I play this continuation I'm
most likely would have won the game
against this you know very strong
opponent but instead we
just making a draw but something good
definitely came out of it is that I
analyzed the position and I learned a
lot about the importance of piece
coordination and how that sort of
relates to the sort of like subjective
value of the pieces right even though
black technically has more material this
rook in the corner is definitely not
worth as much as you know one of my
pieces either this bishop or this knight
right because the rook is not doing
anything but my pieces are becoming
active so I learned a lot about relative
peace value but this new understanding
really helped take my game to a new
level and I want to show you guys a game
that I played I think either one or
maybe even two months later so this is a
game I had two months later and I was
playing white here and ironically I was
actually playing against the very same
opponent who I had in the previous
example so if you want to find the
winning move here for white I strongly
recommend you pause the video it's a
very complicated position so take your
time try to figure out what's going on
try to find the winning continuation for
white okay so the winning move here is
rook takes d6 isn't that great the same
move rook takes d6 was the winning move
in both examples and here I'm glad to
say that I did play this move and I
ended up winning this game
okay so the difference between the two
examples here is that of course in the
previous example there wasn't a whole
lot you needed to calculate right it was
definitely a strategic exchange
sacrifice I gave up the rook for the
knight to ruin black structure make all
their pieces bad it was very much a
correct decision on sort of positional
considerations thinking about the
position abstractly and not in concrete
moves and not in variations this on the
other hand is a tactical sacrifice right
this is Accra Feist is based on
calculating very accurately
and then evaluating the resulting
position so black pretty much has to
take this rook and now Knight takes e5
check and the tactical point behind all
this is that by getting black's rook to
d6 it is now hanging and after the black
king moves somewhere I'm going to take
on g4 and open up this discovered attack
on the rook so pretty much in all lines
what's going to happen is why it is
going to be down in exchange but have
this very strong mass of pawns in the
center and because of that and because
blacks King is going to be much in much
more danger than whites King
this gives why practically a winning
position so I'll show you guys a few
examples to sort of explain here what's
going on
so King g8 was played in the game night
takes g4 and now rope g6 so of course I
have to calculate all these moves before
going through the sacrifice right it is
a combination and when you apply a
combination you have to calculate all
the possibilities and I already saw that
I would have this move Knight f6 check
available to me so now for example of
like king f7 then I can play Bishop
takes h5 and then King f6 I give this
check and I take the rook and I give
this check here so black has an extra
night for the moment but next move I'm
just going to take this 9 on h3 and
obviously why it is completely winning
with these pawns on d5 and d6 the move
plan in the game was King g7 and now Y
can play Knight takes h5 check with a
winning position because again you know
black has a rook for a bishop but these
pawns in the center are extremely strong
and the reason I was able to evaluate
this correctly was because I analyzed
the game before and I realized that you
know when you're down in exchange
if you have sort of these strong ponds
and very good peace activity then
oftentimes that's way more than enough
compensation and it justifies a
sacrifice right and here I found this
move Queen e5 which is quite strong and
the point is I'm attacking the 997 so
just to show you guys how the game went
my opponent player Brooke do you want
check King d2 Knight g6 and here you can
really see the difference in King safety
my King is completely safe because it
has this pawn shelter and blacks King is
very vulnerable to the attack of my
queen and Knight
so now Knight takes h5 check King h6
Queen g7 check King g5 and here a
winning move would have been Knight f4 I
ended up winning this game later but it
was much more complicated than if I just
found this simple move here the point is
that after black takes my takes with the
check and blacks King does not have a
safe spot like King takes f4 Queen f6
check and I win the knight next and then
Y will be up material have this raging
attack and also these two extremely good
pawns in the center so hope that was a
really interesting example for you guys
of how going over your games can and
really does help right and improves your
understanding of the game and it gives
you some sort of familiarity with the
positions you get in the future so
because I analyze so deeply the position
then I shown you guys first the
positional exchange sacrifice it allowed
me to really find the winning move here
which was again oddly enough rook takes
d6 and played with confidence because I
knew very well that that I would
definitely have more than enough
compensation for this sacrifice with
that I wish you guys good luck and I
hope you guys go over your games and
learn a lot and use that knowledge in
your future battles thanks a lot for
listening and I'll see you around on
chess calm